but also more breaking news to talk
about tonight metro police are also
investigating a homicide involving a
two-year-old child this happened near
red rock canyon madison kimbrough has
been on scene all afternoon she joins us
live with the latest madison
yeah this incident described as a murder
suicide happened just along the way here
you can see near the calico basin area
police tell us a woman in her mid-30s
was found dead in her car from an
apparent self-inflicted gunshot wound to
the head authorities also said her child
under the age of two also found dead
beside her in the passenger seat police
say they found a handgun in the vehicle
as well metro police stating that this
unfortunate incident didn't have to
occur as there are places out there to
help
i will tell anyone
who is in a situation where you're under
tremendous stress there are many
resources out in the community you can
call 2-1-1 you can drop your child off
at a hospital you can call child
protective services
it's unknown when the incident occurred
but park rangers were alerted to an
illegally parked car off the side of the
road around 1 15 this afternoon and
that's when bureau of land management
rangers found both the woman and her son
dead calico basin is shut down at this
time residents are only allowed access
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now